♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
THERE IS A WAR ON SPEECH GOING
ON IN AMERICA.
YOUR RIGHT TO SAY WHAT YOU THINK
AS PROTECTED BY THE
FIRST AMENDMENT TO THE
CONSTITUTION.
ON ONE SIDE IS THE ENTIRE TECH
ESTABLISHMENT AND BIG BUSINESS,
HR DEPARTMENT DOWN THE HALL FROM
YOU, ACADEMIA.
ON THE OTHER SIDE IS ADAM
COROLLA AND A FEW OTHER PEOPLE.
LUCKILY ADAM COROLLA CAN HOLD
HIS OWN.
WE SPOKE TO HIM THE OTHER DAY IN
LOS ANGELES AND WE HAVE THAT
INTERVIEW AFTER THE BREAK WORTH
STAYING FOR.
VERY GOOD AND INTERESTING.
BUT FIRST TONIGHT PUT YOURSELF
IN THIS POSITION, IMAGINE BEING
A DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE RIGHT NOW.
IT IS PRETTY HARD TO STAND OUT
IN THE FIELD.
THERE SEEMS TO BE DOZENS OF
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES, MAY BE
THOUSANDS OF THEM.
IT IS A HUGE GROUP, BUT THEY
DON'T DISAGREE ON THE EDGE.
THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED LIKE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY DOES NOT
TOLERATE DISSENT.
EVERYBODY BELIEVES THE SAME
THING.
THE AMISH HAVE MORE INTELLECTUAL
DIVERSITY THAN THE DEMOCRATIC
FIELD.
AS A DEMOCRAT THE ONLY WAY TO
THE NOMINATION WINNING GOLD IN
THE VICTIMHOOD OLYMPICS.
YOU HAVE TO CONVINCE VOTERS WHO
HAVE SUFFERED MORE THAN ANYONE
ELSE.
THAT IS NOT ALWAYS EASY FOR SOME
OF THE CANDIDATES.
CORY BOOKER, FOR EXAMPLE HAS NOT
SUFFERED MUCH AT ALL.
HE GREW UP IN A WHITE NEIGHBOR
OF TWO IBM STANFORD, OXFORD,
YALE LAW SCHOOL AND YET WITH A
STRAIGHT FACE, CORY BOOKER
TELLING YOU ALL ABOUT HIS
TRIUMPH OVER RACISM.
CHRISTIAN JEHLE BRAND CAME FROM
PRIVILEGE, SHE WENT TO DARTMOUTH
PRIVILEGE, SHE WENT TO DARTMOUTL
PRIVILEGE, SHE WENT TO DARTMOUTT
PRIVILEGE, SHE WENT TO DARTMOUTR
PRIVILEGE, SHE WENT TO DARTMOUTL
PRIVILEGE, SHE WENT TO DARTMOUTY
PRIVILEGE, SHE WENT TO DARTMOUTH
PRIVILEGE, SHE WENT TO DARTMOUTN
PRIVILEGE, SHE WENT TO DARTMOUTE
PRIVILEGE, SHE WENT TO DARTMOUTD
PRIVILEGE, SHE WENT TO DARTMOUTA
U.S. SENATE SEAT, SHE TOOK IT
AND DOESN'T MENTION ANY OF THAT
NOW BUT SHE TALKS ABOUT SEXISM
AND THE HARASSMENT SHE
SUPPOSEDLY FACED.
YOU SEE THE POINT.
IN 2019, WHINING IS POWER.
PETE BUTTIGIEG UNDERSTANDS THAT
AND HE MAY BE THE LEAST
DEPRESSED PERSON OF ANY
PRESIDENT.
BOTH OF HIS PARENTS COLLEGE
PROFESSORS, HE WENT TO HARVARD
AND THEN OXFORD AS A RHODES
SCHOLAR AND KENNEDY, WHERE FINER
POINTS OF STUFFING UP THE
CORPORATE AMERICA.
HE GOT AN A IN THAT CLASS.
THE SYSTEM HAS BEEN GOOD TO
PEOPLE TO PETE BUTTIGIEG.
IF HE IS A VICTIM, THEN NOBODY
IS THE VICTIM AND THE TERM HAS
NO MEANING.
SO HOW DOES PETE BUTTIGIEG WHEN
HIS PARTIES AND HOOD OLYMPICS?
SIMPLE.
IT WOULD BE MIKE PENCE STORY.
YOU WILL REMEMBER THE GOVERNOR
OF INDIANA BACK WHEN PETE
BUTTIGIEG THE MAYOR OF
SOUTH BEND.
AS PETE BUTTIGIEG HAS SUGGESTED
RECENTLY, THIS SETS THE TWO OF
THEM ON A COLLISION COURT --
CHORUS.
HE IS IN A TRADITIONAL CHRISTIAN
HE PLANS FOR THE 12TH CENTURY
AND ABOVE ALL HATES
PEOPLE PASSIONATELY AND HOW MUCH
DOES HE HATE PEOPLE?
WATCH THIS EXCHANGE FROM 2015.
HE WAS ASKED DIRECTLY ABOUT PETE
BUTTIGIEG.
YOU CAN SEE THE RAGE IN HIS
EYES.
THE VENOM THAT FLEX IS LIPS AND
MIKE PENCE LOOKS DANGEROUS.
BRACE YOURSELF FOR THIS.
>> I HOLD MAYOR OF PETE
BUTTIGIEG AND THE HIGHEST
REGARD.
WE HAVE A GREAT WORKING
RELATIONSHIP.
AND I JUST SEE HIM AS A
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT AND A
PATRIOT.
>> Tucker: COULD YOU FEEL THAT
I HATE RADIATING FROM THAT MAN?
HIGHEST PERSONAL REGARD.
IN OTHER WORDS, OH, WAIT FOR ME
CENTER, YOU ARE FILTHY AND
REPULSIVE!
GREAT WORKING RELATIONSHIP SAYS
MIKE PENCE, SURE.
AMONG EVANGELICALS THAT IS CODE
ONCE I ESTABLISH MY THEOCRACY I
WILL THROW YOU IN MY DUNGEON AND
LET YOU ROT FOR ETERNITY,
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT
PATRIOT.
OH, PLEASE.
MIKE PENCE WOULD SPIT AND PETE
BUTTIGIEG FACE AND CALL THEM A
REPLICATE THE SAME IS BASHING,
BUT PETE BUTTIGIEG IT IS
RESPONDED TO ATTACKS LIKE THESE
AS YOU WOULD EXPECT AND WARMLY
GAVE GOVERNOR PANTS I LOVE
T-SHIRT AND JOINED HIM ON A
FITNESS WALK.
HE WROTE ABOUT IT ON FACEBOOK IF
YOU WANT THE UNNERVING DETAILS
ON TIME.
TO THIS DAY, HE SEEMS
TRAUMATIZED BY HIS EXPERIENCES
WITH MIKE PENCE.
BUT BUTTIGIEG TOLD THE CROWD IN
AUSTIN "NOT JUDGE MY STATE BY
FORMER GOVERNOR."
HE ACCUSED PENCE SOCIAL
EXTREMISM.
A CHEERLEADER OF THE STAR
PRESIDENCY.
ON CN BUTTIGIEG SUGGESTED THAT
GOD HIMSELF DISAPPROVES OF
MIKE PENCE >> MY MARRIAGE HAS
MADE ME A BETTER MAN AND YES,
MR. VICE PRESIDENT IT HAS MOVE
ME CLOSER TO GOD AND THAT'S WHAT
I WISH THE MIKE PENCE AS OF THE
WORLD WOULD UNDERSTAND.
IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM WITH WHO I
AM, YOUR QUARREL IS WITH MY
CREATOR.
>> Tucker: I DON'T THINK THAT
WAS WRITTEN BY CONSULTANTS AT
ALL.
YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW MIKE PENCE
RESPONDED TO AN ATTACK LIKE
THAT.
WHEN YOU CALL OUT MAN AS HATEFUL
AS MIKE PENCE WHAT DO YOU GET IN
RETURN?
THEY HATE TSUNAMI.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT MIKE PENCE
DELIVERS.
WATCH THIS.
>> I HAVE KNOWN MAYOR PETE FOR
MANY YEARS AND WE WORK CLOSELY
TOGETHER WHEN I WAS GOVERNOR.
I CONSIDERED HIM A FRIEND.
AND HE KNOWS I DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH HIM.
>> Tucker: MAN, THOSE
EVANGELICALS.
WHEN ARE THEY GOING TO LEARN TO
LOVE THEIR ENEMIES AS THE BIBLE
COMMANDS?
PETE BUTTIGIEG BY CONTRAST AND
EPISCOPALIAN SO HE HAS HIS
CHRISTIAN FAITH BY LATE-TERM
ABORTION AND ATTACKING PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN KIND TO HIM.
IT'S MORE OF EFFECTIVE MEN
TALKING ABOUT THE CITY HE LEADS.
IN 2015, SOUTH BEND'S MURDER
RATE THE SAME AS CHICAGO'S.
AGGRAVATED ASSAULT MORE THAN
TRIPLED SINCE BUTTIGIEG BECAME